you obviously as a us congressman get
paid in u.s dollars uh there are now uh
applications something like maybe strike
that would allow you to pick a
percentage and auto convert on payment a
portion of your salary into bitcoin
would you ever think about doing
something like that and taking a portion
of your salary in bitcoin
yeah why not but i i want to make it
clear i wouldn't restrict it to bitcoin
i mean i know
uh that you and and others in this area
in fact i've got one in my office now i
kind of love him he's uh he wrote me a
thing about maximalist
which uh i'm kind of getting into but
the uh uh
the idea that we can i start to bring
crypto
into the mainstream uh whether it's by
converting some of our salary to that or
by uh allowing organically i will make
it clear because i don't want anybody to
take from my statements that i think it
makes sense to mandate
uh what people uh take as a bargain for
uh value of exchange
but i think organically uh pomp i think
if we allow this to be the opportunity i
think yes i would take advantage of it i
think there's a lot of people who would
and that by the way is how you can
facilitate this evolution that we're in
uh while allowing
the legacy uh financial institutions
to uh if they choose to evolve uh with
the financial industry or not uh and you
can ask some great companies of the past
sears roebuck is one that comes to mind
that chose not to evolve and we know
what happens there i'm going to uh i'm
going to send some folks up there to
minnesota and we're gonna get you hooked
up so you could be the first u.s uh
national politician to take uh part of
their salary in bitcoin i think that uh
that may be good for business for uh for
your campaign and for the state of
minnesota
remember pomp it's still january
it's all right listen for bitcoin we'll
go anywhere let's finally go to the
metaverse to the winters of minnesota or
the summers of florida it's all good
what would it take to put uh bitcoin on
the state balance sheet anything any
conversations there or anything that you
think uh could potentially happen in the
next couple of years in terms of putting
bitcoin on minnesota's balance sheet
i think it's a great idea and i'm just
going to tell you that uh i want to stay
away from the partisan thing because i
could be very critical i but i can be
critical of republicans just as well as
i can be critical of democrats right now
it would take uh
some more forward-thinking leadership uh
you know something like your mayor down
in miami something like
some of the others that the new mayor in
new york
who i find him very interesting because
i don't know
how
what how detailed he is in his
understanding but i don't care because
he's uh he's saying the right things
about being forward thinking and
we could use more of that in minnesota
you know uh pomp we've celebrated uh the
fact and anybody who's familiar with the
old garrison keeler show
we've always celebrated the fact that us
minnesotans are just a little bit better
than average and we should be able to
get this figured out
i love it